Chad Moen believe nation today's message
is strive to improve over to you Karl
Lagerfeld
I never pleased with myself I always
think I could do better I couldn't make
an effort I'm lazy I mean it's
ridiculous I know but I had the healthy
attitude I don't think I should change
my state of mind because when people
start to think about that past their art
and others as very generous I do kind of
apply to art don't be too potential and
you got seeing it that I get never liked
the old Rolling Stones and such any
satisfaction of what I'm doing obviously
it could improve I could do better and I
could do more it's ridiculous but it's
very healthy I think I think this is a
trait that you will see across all
successful people that it's never good
enough that they want to improve that
they want to get better that they're
always looking for feedback and
criticism and what they can do better
and they are their worst critic no
matter what you say how you try to tear
somebody down they are harder on
themselves successful people are harder
on themselves and anything that you
could throw at them and that's the link
to their success
I've been thinking a lot about
celebration recently because I don't
celebrate a lot and probably don't tell
a bit enough and as I research it more
you see that the most successful people
don't actually celebrate a lot you don't
celebrate a ton because what they're
doing is not good enough in their mind
yet right you know I'm wearing the blue
J cap and Here We Go Go juice go I love
baseball for some people just getting to
the major league that's a win that's a
win like I made it I made it to the
major leagues I hit my goal and for some
people you know playing a full season is
their goal and they hit away man for
some people just make it into the
playoffs they can feel I made it to the
playoffs and when some people just
playing in the World Series I played in
the World sphere
that's a win for them but there are
other people who want to be the one of
the greatest of all time they want to be
one of the Great's of the Great's in
their head even if it's delusional in
their heads they see themselves winning
five six seven ten World Series that's
where they want again let's look at that
they're not satisfied so they're
striving to improve improve themselves
improve their teammates improve their
strategy improve to get to that point
because in their mind they're winning
five six seven eight nine ten world
series and so if they win one great it's
a win hey good like celebrate one day
awesome good but it's only a step along
the way because in their minds they want
to be one of the greatest of all time
and so one world series is not enough do
you want to get better and improve and
it doesn't have to be from an eagle
point of view like I want to be the best
it could also be from an impact point of
view and one of the things I remind
myself every day is I have the ability
to change the world and it's my
responsibility to do so it's my
responsibility to do it's my
responsibility to get better at what I
do to serve more people to help more
entrepreneurs I need to get better at my
videos great we crossed half a million
subscribers amazing you know quick
celebration let's go like that's not
enough a million five million ten
million it's not about hitting those
numbers it's about the impact that it
can have is about reaching people with a
positive inspiring empowering message
for them to go and do something amazing
instead of wasting your time watching
gag videos right instead of escaping
your world instead of escaping your job
and having to turn to watching funny
videos or trying to go on vacation right
as an escape I want you to not want to
escape your life I want you to live a
life with purpose and passion and
meaning and that's on me to get better
to reach more people to do it a lot of
you guys are already on board and you're
already taking steps and you resonate
strongly with the message there's a lot
of people who don't get and I'm not good
enough yet to be able to reach all those
people and I need to get better that's
how I see it
I need to get better every day I need to
improve I want to have that kind of
impact where I'm winning the five six
seven eight nine ten world series so
hitting one isn't enough and that's why
those the big-time winners the guys are
guys and girls revving like that big
impact they can't relate to the person
who their biggest moment in their life
was getting to the game to playing their
first game in the major league like if
that's your ceiling that's the ceiling
that you imposed on yourself that's the
biggest win in your life getting there
you just can't relate like I don't want
to celebrate that I want to celebrate
doing much bigger things and so I think
having that mindset of striving to
improve of it never being good enough
about they're always being a way to make
it better about taking the personal
responsibility right like if I look at
my videos there's a team of people
around me we're helping me make these
and it's on all of them to get better
too but it's not their fault for not
getting better it's my fault it's my
fault for not coaching them for training
them for improving them for giving them
the mindset motivation to get better and
it's on me I'm doing the product so I
need to get better this this
conversation has to get better has to be
more impactful and so I think if you
look at any successful person people
reach the heights that they're at they
don't just sit back they'll recognize it
for a little bit but then let's move
forward let's make this better how do we
improve how do we even have a bigger
impact on this planet and I sincerely
hope that for you as well so the
question raised today is I'm curious how
much time did you spend celebrating
leaving the comments below
I'm going to join the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to
William from Nucor comm Williams thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really needs a lesson me appreciate the
support thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself hey
whatever your one word is much love and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
they believe nation if you want some
more videos on striving to improve to
really lock in that message in here I
think you're going to enjoy these bonus
clip boy this is the first time in years
doing this all for remembrance it's hard
to remember an old computer language
[Music]
another one designed this every little
metal trace that you see on here I
scrapped on onto a drafting table and I
built this whole board myself because I
wanted the chips in the ultimate perfect
position I worked for a couple of weeks
every night till about 4:00 in the
morning laying out the little things on
a big drafting table that would
eventually become this board and when I
got done I realized I had to drill eight
holes in the board and I said you know
what if I had only designed it a little
bit differently then I would have only
had five holes I tore apart my entire
design for another two weeks every night
till 4:00 in the morning to get it to
that perfect with only five holes you
would never see the three mystic it had
to be that articulate perfectly because
it represents yourself when you do
something to do a great deal on whatever
you really really really want you get
and whatever you really really really
don't want you get because whatever your
mind is focusing on you pull these
things into your life so your
perspective is so important and for me
it was a slow slow slow slow build but I
got me out of that depression and really
lifted me up and I mean and every and I
don't lose you know and something you go
like this you know it's not just a
straight you know and but but I've I've
always kept that desire you know what I
mean and it's a sincere desire and when
you ask for something like that you
start seeing things about yourself
because really the way the world is
relative it's the way you use for
yourself that shapes the world you know
doesn't shape the world that shapes your
perspective on the world so if you want
to continually change you have
to have that desire you know so you know
I can pinpoint certain things in my
certain points in my life where you know
you have these moments of clarity you
know like I was talking about the
academic portion the clarity of the
guitar but there's really these we all
have these very subtle intuitive moments
of clarity but you have to want them if
you're stuck in a particular way of
thinking for your whole life you're not
going to get them you have to see them
you have to want to be you want to how
you want to you have to want to improve
yourself as a person well it's not about
not killing it's about doing the best
show that you can do and it's about
staying at a at the edge of your ability
doing a better I want to do a better
show every time I'm on stage I mean part
of it is that I want to keep I want what
I do to keep getting better unless you
think you're the best comedian that ever
could possibly you're perfect
crystalline diamonds of a comedian that
couldn't possibly be improved upon every
molecule has been compressed together to
the point there's no air in it right
your VAT you're a black hole of a comic
that can't there's just no room for
improvement you know you folded the
samurai sword a thousand times and just
can't fold anymore no so you got to keep
trying I mean I think a lot of people in
show business in comedy even especially
are very lazy and they just sort of
think that you just get up there and
then you wait for your manager to get
you a better one I'm a better shot but
it's it's something you got a really to
me I mean for me I just want to keep
working at it and it would yeah I
wouldn't like it if I stopped trying
really hard it isn't a neurosis like oh
geez I hope they like me it's this is
what I do I got to do it really really
well
for me I would say it's all driven by
curiosity and the desire to be
personally challenged those two things I
can sum up sum it all up and I don't
know if if it's a if it's a formula for
success it's just what what drives me
very curious I want to know more I
choose projects that I'm going to learn
from I choose projects that are
challenging I don't
want to do the same thing twice so I
think you know I think personal
challenge you know trying trying to to
strive for excellence and to me that the
in filmmaking the excellence is how
excellent can the the entertainment
experience be for the audience and I'll
pull out all all stops